Speaker 1: All right. Dozens of you over the
Memorial Day weekend sending me these clips of
Donald Trump on the golf course, giving a short
interview. Everybody's saying Trump looks sick.
David, Something is clearly wrong with Trump. He's
pale, he's low energy. His everything about him,
just his face is sagging and all these different
things. I'm going to look at the clips. Let's see
what we have. He also is, I guess, addressing some
issues about Ron DeSantis. If you were on a debate
stage with Ron DeSantis, what would you say to
him? What would be your interactions with him.
Speaker 2: With Charlie Crist? And he got very
badly beaten and Adam Putnam beat him. I don't
I don't know. But they say he's not a very good
debater. But maybe inside we'll find out, maybe
because unless he gets close,
why would anybody debate?
Speaker 1: All right. So Trump, they're suggesting
he might not even debate DeSantis unless DeSantis
gets close in polling. Yeah, I mean, listen, Trump
doesn't look good. I think what's going on here
and I'm not trying to be funny or disrespectful
or anything, is when Trump doesn't have
the, you know, the dyed hair perfectly quaffed and
perfectly for Trump is an open to interpretation.
The spray tan, the suit, the entire thing.
Trump's an obese older guy. And so this is
just what he looks like. I think I think it's
that simple. I don't know that Trump is sick
necessarily. Here's another clip. And Trump
does seem worse in this one, where he goes
after DeSantis for being disloyal. Are you angry,
Mr. President, that Ron DeSantis entered the race?
Speaker 2: No, I think he's a very disloyal person
because he was dead. He was looking for jobs,
and I endorsed him and he went up many
points. He was 30 points down, at least,
maybe more than that he was dead. So I think he's
very disloyal, but I don't care. Look, a poll just
came out in Iowa. You saw the one that just came
out a little couple of minutes ago. I'm leading by
30 or 40 points. I don't mind that at all.
But no, I think he's very disloyal. But
he's got no personality. You don't have
personality politics. It's a very open.
Speaker 1: Sir. Hey, listen, I actually agree with
this analysis. DeSantis, his personality is just
so the opposite of what anybody would ever want
to see at a dinner party or in in the Oval Office
that I it's obviously it's not just that he's also
a dangerous authoritarian wannabe. I think Trump
is actually right about that. Trump doesn't look
good. He looks exhausted. He looks pale. You know,
the eyes are almost swollen shut. I agree.
I think it's more of it. His energy seems to
be suffering. Does he have what it takes for
this campaign, particularly if he's trying to
beat off one or one indictment, two indictments,
potentially three indictments? I think there are
some real questions there, but not a great
interview for the failed former president.